dude you are a man's man and you're a
brilliant dude be straight with me be
straight with me right now do you think
the current leadership of the democratic
party specifically is beholden to the
american people of the global community
i have no idea who they're beholden to
at this point i really don't i don't
know how to answer that question i i
honestly don't know i wish i could say
that upholding the american people but
given my personal experience over the
last year i don't know who they're
beholden to i really don't i also tell
you this they have a problem on their
hands because they lost my vote
and they don't seem to figure they
haven't seemed to figure that out yet
there's a sizable portion of people like
me
who if trump runs again i'm not going to
vote for biden i'm not going to vote for
trump
and
that's a problem they don't
they're
they have unified government this is why
i think it's so important to santos
rounds man they have unified they've
unified government
and yet they can't seem to accomplish
anything and
you're right i
they don't seem to be a party that cares
about the average american worker
anymore and i think that's honestly why
hillary one of the biggest reasons why
hillary is a terrible candidate to run
the first place considering where she
was politically in terms of the american
people saw her right but she i agree
with you she had active disdain for the
for the plebeian and that's the thing
about it right is trump appealed to a
bunch of people who feel like they've
been left behind
that they've been abandoned right that
nobody has their backs they have been
right they have been
and i don't know if there is a party in
this country that speaks to those people
anymore i really don't i don't think the
republican party by the way is a party
anymore i think it's a cult it's a cult
of personality
when friends of mine like added a common
enemy when friends of mine like adam
kinsen and pete meyer don't have a home
right when they're being just an amish
when they're being actively primaried
like adam's a great guy he's a really
good he's a true america he's a patriot
he gives a [ __ ] about this country right
pete meyer has been a friend of mine for
15 years
right pete gives a damn about this
country to the point that he got on a
plane and flew to afghanistan in the
middle of the evacuation trying to help
out just because he thought as a vet in
a member of congress he might be able to
get people through the gate faster like
he took a lot of [ __ ] for that by the
way for what he did because people
called it a political stunt he was just
going over there trying to help out like
he's a guy who gives it these are all
people who are being actively targeted
because they didn't bend the knee to the
dictator and that's what frightens me
about trump this idea that if you are
i'll give you my favorite example one of
my business partners is a died in the
world republican during the 2016
election he entered the election by
bundling cash for jeb bush when jeb bush
dropped out he wrote one paper a
national security policy position paper
for lindsey graham
because he wrote a position for graham
in the primary the trump world deemed
him not politically
allegiant enough to ever serve in the
trump white house he was banned he was
banned he told me i cannot get a job in
this administration because i didn't
show enough fealty that terrifies the
[ __ ] out of me that that such mafioso
[ __ ]
that's not how you get good governance
that's how you get nepotism what are you
what are you talking about though like
matt like the bb uh you say a comment
like that you got to look at it on the
other side as well
uh you just talked about on the biden
side you know we opened up the meeting
with
saying how come they haven't had you on
media since three four months ago they
don't want to hear the truth yeah so so
this isn't a
loyalty is expected from both sides
don't get a twist this is not like awful
i don't disagree that it's awful but
loyalty is expected from both sides you
you can't just look at it from the one
side to the other side so no i i also i
i i listen i'm not here to listen i'm
just bringing i bring up trump because i
personally hate the guy okay and i think
he's honestly the biggest threat to this
country is long-term survivability i
know that you guys might be fans but
that man is i'm not trump
i'll put it in 2017
i'll show you the notes you can take a
look what does that say what date is on
that
january 1817. january 18 2017 these are
notes that i wrote two days before he
took office it's entitled how they take
over or if i were putin here's how i'd
take over
the guy
is a russian asset and i know you don't
want to hear this but i'm telling you
this is someone who used to know i
worked this is the steel dock
listen it's his behavior
why is it that he meets with putin
one-on-one without translators in the
room and we never get a transcript from
it why because he's checking in with his
[ __ ] handler all right i used to do
this for a living you don't think i can
look and see you don't think i can look
across the table and see somebody that i
would have recruited he's a [ __ ] he
lost me there
explain why explain why all right so the
russian playbook is all about what's
called different disinformation
compromise sure compromising i had jack
barski on two weeks ago he's a former
kgb i'm fully aware of what you're
talking about so look at how trump then
engaged with the american people any
time he was criticized it's fake news
he went and targeted people who wouldn't
bend the knee look who got attacked
constantly by trump world mccain in
particular they went after john mccain
why because he was the only member of
the party without enough clout that
might be able to push back on his cult
of personality so what do they do they
try to go after his legacy they try to
go after and get compromising
information to him why is it that
lindsey graham flips like this lindsay
flips like this because lindsay is gayer
than the day is long and he's afraid
that if that comes out in south carolina
he doesn't get reelected
that's why he suddenly goes from being
john mccain's best friend i remember
them when they were like i used to hang
out with these people i saw them they
were dear friends you're dropping some
absolute bombs right and what you're
telling me what does this have to do
with russia go back to the world but i'm
telling you this is a so make your point
on russia that's what i'm curious trump
is trained to act like a russian asset
would he's trained to take over power in
the way a russian asset if they were in
place would
look at what he's gotten us to do in
four years we all now yell at each other
we don't trust anything that was obama's
second time
but but we don't we really don't trust
it now he poured jet fuel why if you're
an american president is your job to
unite and lead this country and make it
better
or is it hold on do you feel like you
came out of that presidency more united
or more divided more divided for sure
okay hold on hold on i listen to you
guys talk for 10 minutes my turn sure
all right if you feel like you came out
of it more divided let me ask you this
what is the job of the american
president it's to fight for this country
it's to make this country great again
for example you really feel like you
came out of this great you really feel
that the antimonster and the strife that
we all feel when we talk about this son
of a [ __ ] is good no this is exactly
what our enemies wanted i agree this is
putin's wet [ __ ] dream and so this is
what i come back to
i went to a birthday party two weeks
before two weeks after the 2016 election
it was a bunch of polish family they had
come here they'd grown up in poland
under communism yeah
i was landing on the back deck with the
dad
and we were talking about the election
and i asked him so what do you think he
goes do you want my honest opinion i go
yeah and he goes
you americans have no experience with
what just happened to you
this is how they take over and by the
time you figure it out it'll be too late
and it terrifies me because i love this
country and i i it's stuck in the back
of my mind this whole time right
sentimental story but uh no matter
look look at what's fascinating is i
what's fascinating is i see it the same
way but i see it from a different
perspective
so to me i mean everything you're saying
i agree with but i'm saying to myself
this started with
a second term
the division look i'm sorry you don't
think he's an asset look what he tries
to do he discredits nato nato is the one
thing that has kept russia in check for
70 years and suddenly he's questioning
them to pay their bills why is it that
every foreign policy thing that that man
did was in favor of putin why is it that
it always benefited putin that is the
one commandment the chinese trade deal
benefited putin yes absolutely the
chinese trade video benefits putin oh
are you kidding me no seriously all
right russia is sitting right next to
china they're part of the belt and road
strategy that china wants it's an
integra they're trying to integrate a
market over there anything that benefits
china helps out russia's economy
russia is just as dependent as the
chinese as we are they don't want the
chinese economy to collapse just as much
as we don't
you you have to understand putin is
playing a much much longer game the best
way i just heard it described is when
the cold war ended we spiked the ball at
the one yard line we didn't put our our
throat you know our foot on their throat
this is a kgb officer who couldn't stand
the fact that his country lost and he's
been playing the momentum
let me ask a question let me ask a
question so go back and tell us this
saint of yours that was perfect at
foreign policy who do you put as a
standard who's the gold standard for you
i don't think there's a saint in the u.s
foreign so give us the gold standard
harry truman harry truman is your gold
standard if if you were to pick an
american president that was able to
articulate i mean truman the trump
people you hate this guy you you hate
trump you wonder why i hate you yeah i'm
i'm still curious people like you seem
to like him are you out of your mind are
you do you know people like me i like
people like me escape the [ __ ] of
people like you the bottom two no no no
no no no the game's me and played
against guys like him i think you're
what makes this country great and i
can't figure out why someone is smart
i'm gonna explain to you why like but no
it's not it's not but wait a minute you
make it seem like this is a trump
podcast no it's not but like i don't
understand
forgive me yeah the way i look at him is
binary i i can't look at him and see
good things
i can look at obama and see good things
i can look at biden and see good things
i can look at bill clinton see good
things then you're better than i am it's
not about being better than you are
buddy it's it's not about that i love
america and i don't look at people
from the standpoint i've sit down with
mobsters gangsters i've sit down with
you know communists i love talking to
communists because it's a great
conversation for me i don't sit there
and say i hate this guy see the
challenge with your side because you
sound like a broken record right now as
if it's cnn or msnbc do you know what
happened to their ratings when the world
find out found out they were full of
[ __ ] with russia go look at their
ratings go look at their ratings the
week after the world find out this
entire dossier was funded by a lady
named hillary clinton what happened to
the ratings afterwards you know why
because americans were sitting there
saying we believed you
schiff
we believed you guys
cuomo we believed you lemon we believed
you cooper we believed you and you
fooled us
and now brian williams was a guy that
interviewed you says what i'm done with
this i'm worried because what's going on
to america today and he's stepping away
so for me when it comes down to guys
that come out and say things like that
about trump and russia oh my gosh like
who tell me one president first of all
let's let's put the truth out there
has this been a guy that his entire life
has been a master troll and a bully
yeah yes i don't disagree
has this been a guy that came from the
streets of new york where negotiations
are all hardcore and you got to go
against other guys that are also
hardcore because new york's dna is like
you are this is what i like is that how
new york is yes this is new york cna
america is not matt ziller no america's
not chris christie america is not
hillary clinton or trump america's not
cuomo america is more tyler america is
more just a regular person that loves
his country right right okay and then
you come out and you say russia russia
russia russia russia when this guy was
president let me tell you what policies
i like i go policies if you want to talk
emotion personality you can hate that
guy's personality you can sit there and
say this guy knows the hell out of me i
know people that hate obama hate obama
every obama interview i've ever watched
whether it's with leno whether it's with
whoever i've never seen an interview
where i didn't like hearing him speak i
would say i'd love to watch a game with
this guy doesn't mean i agree with his
policies so the emotions i pull out and
i say okay let's look at policies
uh when this guy took office he was the
first guy that was not afraid of facing
off china first guy that's it you want
to do this tariff you want to do this
tariff you want to do this tariff look
where we are today
these barrels that we were getting from
china that was 2500 bucks a pop now it's
what containers 40 000 a container you
think he will let them charge forty
thousand dollars today hell
but biden says what oh uh uh end of
message
end of message what end of message
you're giving a speech on the guy that
passed away end of message
trump stood up against china trump was
willing to sit down with these guys
negotiate trump did palestine and israel
like that's ridiculous to be able to do
what he did 25 years economy was doing
good for whites blacks asian hispanics
women everybody but media hated this guy
why because he called that [ __ ] and
that's his flaw his fault his fault was
the following if somebody as an advisor
gives him a fault as the following
charles barkley said this the other day
kevin durant asked him said how come
you're not on twitter
he says you know i'm not on twitter he
says why he says because i'm old school
if i'm on twitter and people talk [ __ ]
to me i feel like it's my responsibility
to respond back that's barkley guess
what that's trump
trump needs to avoid 99 of the [ __ ]
people say to him and you just focus on
the one percent he wanted to fight
everybody and he made his life a living
kill that's on him but that's how he's
wired you that that comes with the
territory but to say the guy's a russian
asset matt i mean you can say you
disagree with his policies you can say
you know
stormy daniels mcdougall you can say
grab and buy this with the bush story
you can say all you can say mccain which
was an absolute to me
what the hell are you doing going after
somebody pow this guy served the
military you don't have the right to
call out another military person how
come all these generals you don't get
along with what happened with mattis
what i get in millie i get some of these
guys but what happened with some of
these other guys of course all of that
stuff fully agree i totally get it but
sit there and just put it all blanket
hillary clinton just came out and said
the following she said uh i don't know
if you guys read this or not hillary
clinton warns 2024 presidential election
could be the end of democracy national
review hillary clinton warned that
former president trump is close poised
to run for election 2024 and said that
if he wins american democracy will
suffer irreparable damages if i were a
betting man a betting person right now
say trump's going to run again i think
that would be the end of our democracy
not to be point about it but i want
people to understand that this could be
a make it or break it point if you or
someone of his ilk were once again to be
elected president especially if he had a
congress that would be doing his bidding
you would not recognize our country for
many outside observers it looks as
though trump is gearing up to launch a
campaign for 2024. 90 chance this guy's
running you know what i know he's going
to be running
but i agree with what she said by the
way i think it is if he wins it'll be
the end of our democratic we are not a
functioning we're not by the way we're
not a functioning democracy right now
people said if people said a federal
level
if obama gets elected
here but we're not a functioning
democracy anymore on a federal level
we're not okay absolutely or not unpack
unpack that
okay so
how do they begin um
you have one political party again that
is a cult of personality
okay they're they they do whatever
donald trump wants there's no party
platform anymore right there's just
whatever trump wants and i know that you
keep saying he's not a russian asset but
why did they change the right of the
republican party changed the platform at
the republican party convention in 2016
when it came to ukraine once he took the
nomination why was it that was changed
why did he try to pull us out of nato
i'm sorry you you had everything you the
one thing that you never the one thing
that you never said to me that explained
is his russian policy
after all the investigations show one
proof he's a russian asset instead of
just making accusations so the proof for
example if somebody says biden daddy the
big guy 10 million dollars there is
proof okay the the new york times story
when it was blocked by twitter how much
money look at how much money he gets
through deutsche bank who do you think
funds deutsche what i'm trying to tell
you is show me
the last three and a half years you know
you think what kind of investigation
could they have done shitty businessman
he can't even get lended to by anybody
other than the one bank that the
russians specifically fund i'm sorry
like come on stop it
you're saying he's a shitty businessman
absolutely he's a shitty business he's a
horribly shitty you're losing
credibility on that side really this
guy's a bad business how many of his
casinos went bankrupt how many
contractors did he never pay he's losing
his hotel in washington dc right now it
works
really how do you think business works
he had daddy's money you know they did
they figured out that if he had taken
the loan his father gave him in the 70s
he had simply just invested in an index
fund he'd be worth 25 billion today
that's how you know he's a shitty
businessman he couldn't even keep up
with the market
yeah so so so that that just to me
bleeds envy and frustration and
frustration here you're upset no he's
just it's totally fine if you are upset
with the guy no when i'm upset is what
he's done to my country
what he did to your country in four
years
yes he poured jet fuel on a fire you're
you're the president united states
you're supposed to unite us who's the
last time who's the last unifier we had
in america that's a great question i i i
you know i've been thinking that for a
long time so i've been i've been really
trying to ask myself like who would be
the last it probably is reagan
you'd think like maybe because like we
think about like when it's the last
landslide election
i think bill was uh i think bill was uh
able to get both sides to dylan dylan
was the contract with america fantastic
you take you take monica lewinsky take
that out that's fair okay maybe maybe i
say bill and reagan that that's kind of
the start of the the monica lewinsky
thing i think is kind of the start of
this hatfield and mccoy fight that
actually it starts with the contract of
america and the reason why is it starts
in the 94 election so the 94 election
you have to understand this is a seminal
election in american history it the the
house of representatives at that point
for 40 years has been held by the
democratic party okay the senate slipped
a couple of times but the house has been
held for four think about that
that's my entire life right 40 years
okay used to be the working man party
that's why so
here's what happens in 94. newt gingrich
goes around to all the republican
folks running for office that year
against democrats and he says here's the
common strategy you're going to ask the
person you're running against in the
debates can you name the price of milk
back home i remember that and
elected members couldn't and the reason
why was because the culture in
washington at the time was if you got
elected to the house or the senate
you moved your family to dc you didn't
go back home to your district maybe
other than a couple of times a year you
absorbed into the swamp but but you you
you met people you went to the same
church together a synagogue together
your kids played on the same little
league teams right your spouses knew
each other socially
it made compromise and working together
easier because these were people that
you had personal relationships with that
you might have policy differences and
disagreements right i don't think
patrick and i are ever going to agree on
trump being a russian asset but you know
hopefully at the end of the day we can
shake hands and walk away from this
that's that'll always be the case yeah
they don't ever i know that but that's
how washington used to be it doesn't
work like that anymore now because now
they're not there they're there tuesday
to thursday a couple times you know a
couple of weeks a year yeah right and
then they're back home and they're on tv
and they're screaming at each other and
they don't know where they're at
i'm not blaming one side or the other
i'm just saying everything changes with
that one disagree with that and it's
that culture change that i honestly
think changes the americans to link it
but to link it bro to saying trump is
the guy that created the division he
didn't create it we haven't even had
this jet fuel on it to be fair to be
fair
to be fair
is it fair to say
uh let's see if you can be reasonable
here i'm hoping you can be reasonable
here and take the emotions out
is it fair to say
that out of all the
uh people that have been elected during
our lifetime you and i are the same age
i think we're three years apart and he's
two years younger than you
four years younger you're 36 or 30 30 36
36 okay so i'm 43 you're 40 he's 30
you're 40 oh we have 40 in january okay
so you're 39. so okay
is it fair to say the last 40 years
carter winning
reagan winning
senior winning
clinton winning
junior winning the gw winning obama
winning trump winning is it fair to say
the biggest shell shocking winner where
you were like what the hell just
happened is trump uh 100 is it even
close what do you put close to that i i
couldn't i it was such it was such a
shock to my sister i couldn't sleep that
i was at 3 30 up in the morning i'm on
the phone with tom i'm sounds like he
won i said no
new york times just reported it i said
there's no hillary's
hillary's got the resume newsweek got
the magazine ready madam i know
everybody that that magazine right now
is like priceless everybody's trying to
buy that magazine because it's so hard
it's like a limited edition product
right
we're sitting there like this guy just
won okay so imagine a guy that's an
underdog comes in talks [ __ ]
calls everybody out whether he's right
or wrong and half of america votes for
this guy so either half of america
is a bunch of idiots deplorables which
you and i agree that they're not they're
angry and frustrated i agree and not and
they felt that he tapped into something
that he he that he heard them beautiful
it's less about him guys i'm telling you
it's about more about the to the voting
against versus voting for it
my entire family is democrats and i'm
telling you they're they're gone they're
off the rails they have not voted
democrat for the first time in their
lives because they do not feel like
these ivy leaguers are always talking
about them they're always lecturing them
they're always blaming them and it feels
like these people
have the international community's best
interest in mind and not our best
interest in mind and we resent that
so that's that's where this comes from
and donald trump tapped into it he
pulled one of the greatest he pulled one
of the greatest
illusions of all time this is a guy that
that grew up 90 floors above everybody
else with a silver spoon in his mouth
and somehow convinced west virginia coal
miners he was one of them
so i mean that that just goes to show
you how badly and honest to god matt and
this is this is kind of where where i i
see it differently than you do
he took the obama playbook the obama
political playbook and i think obama is
the greatest politician of my lifetime
but he took their playbook
and turned it on its head and ran their
playbook
you disagree with me
well you're racist you disagree with me
you hate america took the exact same
tactics
inverted it and if you think that's
pouring fire maybe it is to me it's a
galilean dialectic you see somebody do
something and it works what do you do
you emulate it
so one of the other big things that
happened for a guy like me over these
last four years i did not vote for trump
the first time i did vote for trump the
second time because i felt like
democrats did not learn their lesson
at some point they just had to be like
you know what guys
socialism is a touchy issue we haven't
we're asking for a lot of the hours of
your life and taxes and we're not really
showing our work here and there's a ton
of waste in government that we're not
addressing at all but we're just asking
you for more and more and more of your
money
maybe we shouldn't have just said if you
disagree with us you're racist that was
probably a bad tactic sorry about that
that's kind of all they had to do so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]